[Musik]
hey das geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video durch bin hat ein
bisschen abgefuckt weil wir haben
eigentlich das video bis zum zweiten
produkt schon aufgenommen
dann ist irgendwie die speicherkarte
abgekratzt und die ganze aufräumen aber
beschädigt so dass wir jetzt nochmal
starten müssen halt ich habe es eben
schon gesagt ich habe sehr muskelkater
aber ich gerade wieder sport machen und
deswegen würde ich sagen du kannst dich
hinsetzen
vielleicht kennst du dich wo wir plätze
tauschen du machst es dann ich sitze da
dann lass uns das noch machen
15.000 live.com du ein video will ich
machen ich kann man ein ganzes stück
nach den ersten schritt und dann musst
du das produkt aus kann man nicht mal
die kamera 20.000 leicht 10.000 und
20.000 1000 ich habe auch ihren
kommentar gelesen seine stimme hört sich
so im park gehören will ich den
deutschen unter der kormoran also auch
schon gelesen gehört auch sympathisch
man kann aber darstellen viele immer
noch meinen namen falsch mit jj o'barry
stimmt nicht also okay leute zurück zum
thema heute geht es oben
also ich habe ja in letzter zeit wobei
es kam letztens schon die airport fakes
von jugend für drei euro die günstigsten
erfolg sehe ich irgendwo gefunden hab
hab ich bestellt und getestet war
eigentlich im flop schaut euch das video
trotzdem sehr gerne an und dazu habe ich
noch zehn kostenlose produkte bestellt
von jugend- oder zumindest also eine
eure sachen wo man halt einen euro für
den versand bezahlt und hinzu kamen noch
weitere sachen die ich gar nicht so
richtig identifizieren kann also die
habe ich einmal gekauft weil ich die
interessant fand deswegen wie dieses
video am ende heißt weiß ich nicht es
könnte vielleicht so technik gadgets
heißen wobei das auch so ein bisschen
vermischt ist wir haben nämlich
irgendwas für die dusche wir haben das
für zimmer und wir haben etwas für den
körper sondern musste gerät um den body
halt für zwei
da habe ich glaube ich sogar 15 euro
bezahlen ich würde sagen wie lange ich
zeige euch mal das
ein produkt das ist auch schon bei uns
im bad weil ichs grad schon montiert
habe wie gesagt die aufnahme ist eben
abgebrochen
wir sind hier immer so ein bisschen
unzufrieden mit unserem buch spruch
verlegen
er ist ja schon ein bisschen verhalten
und dann kommt nicht mehr so gut wasser
raus da hab ich gedacht hey was auf darf
ich gedacht er hier dieses ding für
mittlerweile sind auch drei euro ich
habe da eigentlich fünf euro bezahlt das
sieht geil aus dass bestellst du dir und
genau das habe ich auch gemacht das soll
nämlich sogar wasser sparen und da
kommen so wie ihr sehen könnt ganz ganz
viele kleine strahler aus insgesamt hat
das 300 tonnen löcher sind es oben
das fand ich halt interessant und habe
es bestellt und ich würde sagen wir
haben es gab schon getestet aber ich
zeige dir jetzt noch mal für die kamera
und dann sage ich euch ob ich damit
zufrieden war oder nicht so gut dann ab
ins bad
denn wir haben ja schon ein bisschen
vorbereitet da oben könnt ihr den
duschkopf ich hab noch gar nicht viel
zeit kann muss er in einer lache
was ist das denn scheiße qualität habe
ja eben schon gesagt jetzt bin ich
klitschnass gegen den bus wird dann hält
ihn nicht also leute hier könnt ihr das
sehen wir haben hier wirklich 300 löcher
ganz klein ja dann entschieden wir
dieser wassersparende effekt anscheinend
keine ahnung und ansonsten ich war
eigentlich zufrieden so offen erstmals
ein hätte schlimmer kommen können wobei
auch der led duschkopf den wir damals
hatten in ordnung und so war auch
eigentlich ganz nice
[Musik]
das problem ist halt das kommt jetzt
wahrscheinlich extrem viel wasser raus
wie man xing mich darüber heute von
einer umkehr tschuldigung muss die milch
einkaufen ich weiß nicht wer entscheidet
denn so eine scheiße guckt jemand hier
das gewinde haben
das sieht auch schon so aus als wird das
nicht funktionieren können zum teil
kommen schief übrigens alle meine daumen
nach unten viewer gibt nie trinkgeld gut
ich habe jetzt aber was gutes bestellt
noch für dich für dein zimmer und zwar
eine schlanksten led das ist eine
pflanze die man an die wand hängen kann
und die leuchtet wie so weil ich wollte
eine freude machen
wir können uns da auch direkt sehr sehr
gerne mal das produkt anschauen wo ist
es genau hier so sieht das aus und ich
muss sagen hat mich eigentlich auf den
ersten blick fasziniert also vom bild
her oder von den bildern hier sieht echt
schön aus nachtlicht platz fantastische
pilz licht led nacht wand licht adapter
erhalte ich war okay
leider habe ich das produkt gerade schon
gesehen und das ist viel kleiner als ich
ist eigentlich erhofft papst mal so aber
da kann ich mittlerweile auch schon ein
lied von singen dass die produkte die
man bestellt immer deutlich größer aus
den auf den produktfotos und das ist
jetzt alles was sollen wir mit so einem
kleinen dinge
was soll man da nicht was ist diesen
gegenstand zugestoßen auf der reise von
jenson nach köln nach mir das mal dann
ist ja so demoliert wir haben ja glück
wenn es funktionieren würde überhaupt so
wo jetzt das auf geschichten aus spenden
sind
kommen wir gehen wenn mein zimmer kummer
und dass das wechselt sogar die fragen
was man auch und farbe wechseln bitte
also ich finde er ist schon etwas sehr
beruhigen ist ob man es jetzt braucht
oder nicht
dieser andere sache aber für so junge
leute oder so ist das ja etwas gutes so
kommen wir zur nächsten tag war davor
ich mich eigentlich drauf ich habe das
produkt auch schon gesehen weil ich sage
ich ja auch immer ich schaue ich muss
immer rein sportlich pakete damit ich
seit ordnen kann und danach sich auch
das paket was sie täglich ihr zugestoßen
fast nur auf also was steht uns euch
selten gesehen was macht ihr denn damit
fahren die damit einen achtbaren drüber
anders kann das nicht passieren
die kleidung die frage ist so ein
bisschen altmodisch kündigt jedoch auf
was vielleicht daraufhin schließen
findet dass das schon nach jedes made in
china
aber das ist ein bisschen dass die
produktion schon ein bisschen weit in
der vergangenheit liegt sag mal so dann
würde ich sagen wir schauen sie mal kurz
an was ich da bestellt habe ja aber das
war ich glaube ich habe einfach mehr
bezahlt ich dachte eigentlich hat über
10 euro bezahlt jetzt gerade steht hier
nur noch von eur 94 euro ims
muskeltraining fitness ok also es ist
für die apps also hier halt ne wie bei
mir sehr stark ausgeprägt ich zeige euch
das gleiche macht und was macht man dann
wohl darauf dann wackelt das und sollte
das ganze ein bisschen ja ich weiß nicht
dann sollen die bauchmuskeln von alleine
wachsen sagt man ja so nett und wie das
funktioniert schauen wir uns mal an alte
mann
mein ziel ist es wirklich leute die
denken das klappt das auch
[Applaus]
start fatburning also das ist doch dann
will man auch das also ist nichts gegen
leute die irgendwie übergewicht haben
oder so aber die will man damit durch
den kakao ziehen dass man halt praktisch
sich das ding auf schnallt und in dem
man nichts tut abnimmt start fatburning
und das wird aber so nicht funktionieren
leute dafür muss man nicht bewegen
es liegt aber eigentlich beim
professionell auch schon mal hier und
jetzt muss ich dass wir noch auf machen
[Applaus]
da müssen doch wahrscheinlich batterien
rein oder das ding ist jetzt aufgeladen
ich habe es gerade gemacht jetzt passt
auch jetzt klemmt wir das hier an
und jetzt muss ich mir das andere auch
kleben würde ich das dann auch wieder
vom bauch ab
[Musik]
scheiße mann der grand prix ist selbst
rohnstock ich dachte das rüttelt müssen
so strom nicht raus nicht macht an traue
mich nicht länger das kommt das schön
sind
europa ist das denn
ich habe ich wollte den kapitalisten
gehört als ich wollte nie dass du
alleine im leben und ich war die ganze
zeit ausgedrückt was würde er viel
stärker
jetzt habe ich nur ganz kleine terrasse
ist ja echt ok ich kann nichts machen
also bis jetzt auf jeden fall etwas
krasses hatten wir noch nicht so ein
kleines kätzchen oder was heißt geil ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob das was bringt
stellt im vorderen liegt also weiter auf
der couch und kriegen die ganze zeit
suchen zu stromschlägen kommen ja leute
das waren drei sachen war das kann
niemand vertreiben kann sein dass ich
noch eben was habt was ich euch zeigen
kann
[Applaus]
jetzt findet wieder so waren welche dem
ding glaube nicht dass nämlich noch
nichts gegen sachen die für das
kostenlose jugendprojekte video brauchen
das kommt dann auf nächste woche
und ansonsten bis hierhin leute was ich
noch sagen wollte ich stehe mittlerweile
geworden also ungefähr 30.000 bis zu
einer millionen deswegen wird sie mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr den kanal abonniert
mich unterstützt damit wir das event
weil dieses jahr schaffen mehr richtig
cool denn jungs natürlich auch ein
kleines wölfl und ich will mich auch in
die gedanken und gibt es einen neuen
song im neuen songs über song ich kann
keine chance man muss
[Musik]
ein